>> Hello YouTubers. This is Begum Aga Khan
and I'm very happy to join you today. Let
me tell you what I believe is one of the most
important things that all people should be
doing in 2009 in order to fight poverty. It
is called micro-finance and micro-finance
is proved to be one of the most effective
tools to lift people out of extreme poverty.
And the good thing is, it can be done by everyone,
actually governments, businesses, banks and
every single person like you and me. Let me
explain how it works. Think about 1.4 billion
people who are living in extreme poverty in
developing countries. They have to live every
day with less than $2, and they have no extra
for basics. In other words, they have no clean
water, they have no safe housing, no medical
care, and no education. Now the good thing
is that it takes a relatively small amount
of money to lift these people out of poverty
by granting them small loans called micro-loans.
For example, a small amount of money like
$150 can lift a whole family out of this vicious
circle of poverty and with this amount of
money they can start building their little
business and for the first time take control
of their life, for example [inaudible] and
Richard Stewart. Let me give you an example,
my Princess Inaara Foundation recently announced
a fund raising campaign in the German city
of [inaudible] and in yet in four weeks we
were able to collect more than half million
euro for poor families, for women and their
families in Southern India. And with this
money alone, we will be able to reach out
to by 2010 to more 100,000 more families than
we are reaching out to now. So in other words,
what I want to say is it works, it is fantastic
and all of us can do it. So please do join
in the fight against poverty. Let us invest
together in the poorest members of our society
thereby helping, shaping this world into a
better [inaudible]. Thank you.